♪
(gun shot)
Dick:
I know what you're thinking.
♪
Dick: Who is this guy
with the incredible cheek bones?
Where does he get his hair done?
One day, I'll be
the most famous highwayman
in all of England!
You are literally
about to be hanged,
you idiot!
- (laughter)
- Dick: Quick note to my gang.
If you were planning a rescue,
now would be a good time.
- ♪
- (yells)
- (gunshot)
♪
You've probably heard of me.
Dick Turpin?
New leader of the Essex gang?
Nell:
Highwaymen murder and rob.
You're not highwaymen, Dick.
I've got this. We strike on three.
One, two…
(horses running)
We'll get the next one.
- ♪
- I've seen you prancing around
- in your funny shirts.
- (imitates gunshots)
Dick: I'm new school, and
there's gonna be less violence
on my watch.
Is there anything
that I could've done
to improve
your highway robbery experience?
But we’re just as tough
as any other gang in here.
Here’s your peppermint tea,
Dick.
I put a splash of honey in it,
I know you got
a scratchy throat.
- Dick: Thanks, little Karen.
- ♪
John: There’s only one man
brainless enough
to steal from the syndicate.
(mimics neck snapping)
- (laughs)
- Thank you, Dick.
I don’t know
what we’d do without you.
♪
(yells)
- (clicks)
- (screams)
♪
I’m gonna be famous!
- Dick Turpin!
- Dick Turpin.
Dick Turpin.
I want this Dick in my hands
as soon as possible.
- (snickers)
- That sounds weird.
Yeah, that did sound
a bit weird, sorry.
♪